the star of the movies here and boy did
you make an intro oh how fun was that
cool yeah no it was great it was great
yeah so whose idea was that
like let's get this together let's
really make an entrance I'm coming in
Sean was um we had a lot of creative
meetings about this premiere and it's
how we were gonna launch this damn thing
and I always thought it'd be fun to just
drive around that El Camino just because
I'm obsessed with the car you know the
week leading up to it and we just kind
of came up with his concept and please
tell me they gifted you and El Camino
please tell me that I wanted that thing
so bad right now
no come on come on Netflix okay so this
major this Breaking Bad reunion here is
crazy crazy banana Breaking Bad better
call Saul it's a family you know we
really truly were such a family and I
felt you know like a crazy sort of
messed-up family reunion just telling
the old you know same old crazy messed
up you know story and so it was a lot of
fun so much fun you know everybody is
wondering who's gonna pop up in the
movie what cameos is Brian gonna be in
the movie how hard was it for you to
keep those things to your so easy man
yeah I love surprising people I love
lying to people you know it's easy for
me but so many people just can't keep
things quiet how do you keep the secret
do you like do fake call sheets
disguises yeah yeah we had a we had a
fake name for the film I just I mean I
told my wife obviously and my parents
and and a couple of my friends but
everybody else I just said I was doing a
small little indie project in New Mexico
and no one's second-guessed it some
people maybe thought oh are you doing
better call Saul and I would just say no
they're on a hiatus and yeah Here I am
you know are you glad now though that
you don't do anything anymore we're all
about to see your babies I'm very happy
that it's out in the open it was easy
for me to keep it a secret but I just
couldn't wait for the world to finally
be able to see it and they're gonna
they're gonna really love it you said
you had to sit in silence at the end of
this movie you just had to sit for a
minute yeah that causes some anxiety
with folks yeah well when I read the
script for the first time in Vince's
office and I turned the last page I just
sat there and it just hit me like a ton
of bricks like what this guy just went
through yet again you know and you've
just a deeper look it I don't want to
give away anything but it's just it's
it's a pretty heavy but also a very fun
ride will this movie conclusively answer
the question that everybody wants to
know is Walter White really dead no yes
[Music]
you know what I thought I to be honest I
thought the show answered that we don't
know we think that has a lot to do with
people just wanting more you know which
is a great great great thing could there
be another movie another spin-off would
you would you I mean you know I thought
I said goodbye to this guy so long ago
but here we are and so it's up to this
beautiful man over there but I've said
this so many times I'd follow this guy
into a fire Vince Gilligan I would do
anything he asked me to you're the
finest actor of our generation and he
can't wait to work with you yeah well I
love him to death and we definitely plan
on doing that in the future so whatever
heat whatever whatever he wants really
he's just such an incredible storyteller
and even a better human being if that's
even possible but he's really just such
a sweet sweet beautiful man and feel
blessed to call him my friend and my you
know yeah congratulations my man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]